God versus man
holy Kalama Batman that trailer was so
meaty I'm even know where to begin
really we're about to break down the
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
trailer for all of the details and
Easter eggs that is contained therein
the most epic superhero fight ever we've
been waiting for this for so long
and now it's here I'm de PO writer and
here are all the Easter eggs that you
need to know about in the new Batman vs
Superman trailer this is hashtag news
the trailer actually starts off near the
end of the last movie Man of Steel when
Superman is fighting Zod but we see this
from Bruce Wayne's perspective the tower
that we see getting destroyed is the
Wayne Enterprise Building so Bruce Wayne
is understandably pissed big criticism
of Man of Steel was the huge destruction
of Metropolis at the end so this movie
now takes those consequences and
explores them like the US Senate wanting
to rein in Superman's powers and Batman
wanting to stop him completely this is
how the movies set up but how did all
that metropolis destruction and Man of
Steel affect Batman Zack Snyder at Comic
Con confirmed metropolis and Gotham are
sister cities across the bay from each
other metropolis is the rich Gotham is
the poor kind of similar to real-world
San Francisco and Oakland as opposed to
the classic comparison that they
represent New York and Chicago we have a
new Alfred - played by Jeremy Irons oh I
love Jeremy Irons you know I'm his scar
from The Lion King we see Alfred walking
up to a dilapidated Wayne Manor so we
can assume that this is a new era for
Batman looks like somebody sent Bruce
Wayne an article strip from the
newspaper that says you let your family
die strewn across it this could be the
Joker taunting Batman it is in his
chaotic red handwriting it's a recurring
theme in Bruce's life that the people he
cares for most died his parents his
Robins and now his employees dozens of
them couldn't get an exact number
they're from The Daily Planet just
dozens thanks production designer this
version of Batman is much darker
he's been Batman for decades this is not
new for him he's based on Frank Miller's
Batman from The Dark Knight Returns he's
been fighting criminals for so long he's
grizzled he's jaded this is a much more
brutal form of Bruce Wayne than we've
ever seen before
hence the bat symbol branded into the
tide of bad guy there this form of
vigilantism is also a contrast to
Superman's wholesome way of fighting
crime you know
interesting pep talk with Superman's
mother his continued Zack Snyder
Superman where his parents are telling
him you don't need to save the world at
any cost
but could dawn of justice be introducing
a new unsympathetic Superman who might
not necessarily save everybody take the
scene of people trying to escape this
flood on their rooftop reaching up
toward the deity Superman and him not
necessarily helping them we don't know
Superman was teasing them come on dude
maybe you still want to touch that
pruney hand I mean she's been in the
water so long right all jokes aside
though people are obviously conflicted
in this film about Superman's role this
is probably a main theme of the film is
Superman too powerful for Humanity is
own good or do we desperately need him
to save us from every little kerfuffle
we can't get ourselves out of I think
what we're seeing here is this inner
conflict in Superman that says is
everyone worth saving and here's our
first look at Wonder Woman oh no no no
I'm sorry that's Jesse Eisenberg is this
even same film no no JK he's playing Lex
Luthor and at some point he gains the
upper hand over Superman whether it's a
kryptonite or a hostage situation or
something else entirely
here's mercy graves Lex Luthor's
bodyguard she looks great but no you
know what we're not that shallow here
@mr she's a complex character deadly
fighter originally from the cartoon
Superman the animated series interesting
that Zack isn't pulling from just the
comics but from the animated series as
well here's a dead Zod what are they
gonna do with Zod's Bob there's some
speculation that they could be studying
his corpse to find some sort of weakness
it might be used to create a secret
weapon like the Doomsday character and
if you remember from the comics doomsday
does end up killing Superman so this
could be an important plot point this is
another big moment in the trailer this
outfit looks a lot like Robins you can
see though the yellow glass would be in
the comics the Jason Todd Robin was
killed by Joker with a crowbar pretty
sad
pretty gross if that's true in this
movie then this is a direct reference to
that now in the source material the Dark
Knight Returns Robin is dead so it's
very likely that this is a part of
Batman's mental state if this is the
Joker's handwriting then it's most
likely his attempts to goad Batman now I
for one hope it works a pissed-off
Batman is an awesome Batman also in the
Dark Knight Returns Batman does get a
new Robin as the female Carrie Kelly so
maybe we'll get to meet her at the end -
okay here's gal gadot at a fancy event
her outfit is a nice nod to the 70s
Wonder Woman who wore a white bodysuit
check out those gold chains we should
think she is with that fat chain two
chains there's only one chain right
what's interesting about the inclusion
of Wonder Woman
is that in the comics there are
definitely sparks between her and Batman
and we can see there are obvious in the
trailer but if we stick with the comics
storyline Superman could get mixed up in
this love triangle which would end up
being a very weird very epic pseudo love
affair between Batman Wonder Woman and
Superman now in the comics story line
Wonder Woman sees Superman as her only
worthy mate because they see themselves
on the same level
aka gods among men ah little Easter egg
here Superman is only six foot eight so
technically I'm taller than him awesome
611 no I'm barely six foot I'm standing
on two ugly boxes right now like this is
me cool hurry can we move on here we see
some militarized dudes kneeling before
Superman with s patches on their
shoulders who are these guys they
clearly claim to be his representatives
whether or not he personally dispatches
them words still out I'll call every one
of you personally when I find out Lex
Luthor saying the red capes they're
coming you could refer to this Superman
militia okay not sure what's happening
here it's an underwater shot that could
be a tease for the rumored inclusion of
Aquaman Wonder Woman is here with her
famous bracelets that can stop bullets
and create shock waves this jet could
possibly be Wonder Woman's it's not
invisible though so maybe she's just
leasing the batwing here she is right
next to the destroyed cockpit not doing
much for the stereotype of women drivers
Wonder Woman later we see her with her
lasso of truth which can force anyone to
tell the truth so that probably just
looks like people going you know you're
super attractive yes I find you really
attractive yes I would like to see you
get the idea and he didn't cash this in
the first twenty thousand depictions of
Batman receive whose parents get shot
again but as revealed at comic-con we
now know who's responsible for that
did you enjoy the show Conan I loved it
my doctor Thomas and Martha Wayne know
were the O'Briens he's looking for Bruce
Wayne's mom and dad fernette alley
Thanks
Coenen that's scoundrel guy still love
him though he's still so funny
here we see crowds protesting outside of
Superman's Senate hearing at the Capitol
but then later we see them ducking for
him something what are they ducking from
are they being attacked at Superman's
hearing his Wonder Woman coming in and
telling him to lay off her man here's a
plain-clothed to Wonder Woman getting
into a nice car check out the guy
checking her out easy dude she's way out
of your Justice League don't know really
what's happening here this is a strange
desert land it's rumored that this is a
mascara Wonder Woman's home we do know
that production had to be moved from
Morocco to New Mexico because of an
Ebola outbreak we're on that one
Superman not sure where we are but
something's going down there's no
indication of why it's deserted or why
there's so much destruction this could
be Batman his goggles and trench coat
are reminiscent of his Elseworlds styles
or not he does snap a dude's neck here
so that's kind of against his moral code
it could be one of the sons of Batman in
the Dark Knight Returns there's a whole
plot about thugs that become vigilantes
and call themselves the sons of Batman
they aren't afraid to kill this combined
with Superman's soldiers who could be a
reference to injustice gods among us
video game universe where Superman
becomes a despotic ruler so maybe these
two groups are gonna do get out one can
only pray the destruction continues back
in the city where Lex Corp is on fire
here's Lex Luthor looking at a giant
chunk of kryptonite now that's probably
not how he loses his hair but seeing
that he gets cancer from kryptonite in
the comics it's probably not best to
stare directly at it Lex I know someone
else who might like to get his hands on
some Kryptonite to fight Superman this
is the way that Batman and Lex Luthor
could possibly team up maybe makes sense
that Lex and Bruce know each other
they're both billionaires in the same
square mileage all billionaires always
rub it was they're like let's team up
well we're already rubbing elbows God
versus man
here's a cool moment of Batman
replicating the cover of Frank Miller's
The Dark Knight Returns very cool homage
to the source material so many epic
battle scenes for me expect between
Batman and Superman well it looks like
at least two because of Batman's outfit
changes he's got the classic Batman
outfit and then he has the cooler lit up
eyes version for those of you wondering
how does Batman even stand a chance
against Superman who could like click
his jaw off or look at him and burn him
to smithereens well Superman isn't
trying to kill Batman he refuses to kill
people so this whole fight is basically
grizzled jaded Batman vs Superman moral
compass man that really took the wind
out of our sails didn't it a lot less
epic when you put it that way all right
well there you have it man I'm excited
for this it's gritty and violent just
the way I like my superheroes I must say
I am a bit skeptical that they're not
gonna push it far enough they're gonna
play it safe and not do justice to the
dot of justice so what do you think of
the trailer huh tell us below in the
comments is it too dark not dark enough
honestly how was Batman not gonna die
after the first punch is Superman just
bat him around like a cat and yarn oh
yeah but I you know like this video if
you'd like to speculate further on the
trailers hidden gems or perhaps suggest
a better crossover alternative fast park
7 anyone also guys if you haven't
already please subscribe to our channel
new media rockstars keep up to date with
our latest rumors and speculations and
other pop culture shots in the dark
I've been Gabe hole writer and I'm gonna
go get this design on my shirt branded
into my chest you guys have the brand
right